[Music]
[Music]
okay
welcome to your weekly ticket
well it's official madonna will be
directing a biopic
on her own life the star has tapped
oscar winning writer diablo cody to
co-write the screenplay
the untitled project will be distributed
through universal and will document her
coming up as an artist in new york in
the 80s
and her interactions with andy warhol
keith herring and john michelle basquiat
while madonna has confirmed it will not
be a musical
it will focus heavily on her career
madonna said in a statement
the focus of this film will always be
music music has kept me going and art
has kept me alive
there are so many untold and inspiring
stories who better to tell it than me
it's essential to share the
rollercoaster ride of my life with my
voice and my vision
madonna has previously directed two
features philton wisdom and we
which took home a golden globe award in
2011.
lee isaac chung will direct paramount's
live-action adaptation of the hit
japanese movie
your name chung who directed the
sundance winning film minari has been
tapped to rewrite the screenplay which
had prior drafts by emily v
gordon and a rival screenwriter eric
heiszerer this
reimagined sci-fi love story centers on
a teenage boy and girl from different
parts of japan who discover they can
swap bodies
while they're separated by time and
space when a disaster threatens to upend
their lives they must journey to meet
and
save their worlds and jeff goldblum
james marsden and eva longoria have
signed on to be a part of the a-list
voice cast for the boss baby sequel
alec baldwin will return to voice boss
baby ted with jimmy kimmel and lisa
kudrow reprising their roles as ted's
parents
tom mcgrath who directed the first film
will also return to direct the sequel
the dreamworks animated film which is
titled the boss baby family business
is scheduled to be released on march 26
2021
friday marks the 45th anniversary of the
rocky horror picture show and we're
celebrating by highlighting fandango
now's list of midnight movies
this list includes a mix of genres
anything from jim sharman's the rocky
horror picture show
to stanley kubrick's 2001 a space
odyssey
and today our guest is senior editor at
collider haley fouch to give us her
personal recommendations
from the list haley what is your
ultimate
midnight movie well i have two
recommendations for you today which i
actually think would make a really
excellent double feature
because they're they're killer contrast
about the highs and lows of friendship
they've both got good actually original
songs for their fictional bands
and they both like a lot of midnight
movies didn't find their audience at
first but have developed this really
passionate fan base over the years
and first up is jennifer's body which is
karen kusama's 2009 horror comedy that
was scripted
by diablo cody and the film kind of
arrived at
the peak backlash against juno and megan
fox who stars
and it's just a standout example of like
a completely mis-marketed film because
they sold it as this silly sexy slasher
built around how sexy megan fox is
and it's actually a super sharp
insightful
stylish horror comedy that's all about
toxic teenage friendships
and the corrosive toll of assault and
how that impacts your relationships
and it should have been the film that
made megan fox of juggernut star
because she's incredible in it she stars
as this teenage it girl who gets
possessed by a demon after a ritual
sacrifice gone wrong
and it focuses on the aftermath of that
trauma how it
affects her relationship with her best
friend needy played by amanda seyfried
also super underrated a lot of the time
it's just funny and freaky
it's sexy it's subversive and it holds
up
is super relevant all these years later
and as a bonus it's got great
appearances from
kyle garner jk simmons and adam brody
and i dare you to get through the trees
out of your head
and then after you go dark with
jennifer's body
you can uh sort of boost your mood with
harry elfont and deborah kaplan's 2001
live-action
adaptation of josie and the pussycats it
is like a perfect counterpoint about
friendship it stars rachel
cook rosario dawson tara reed as josie
and the pussycats it was similarly
dismissed but
has endured thanks to its radiant
positivity
an excellent soundtrack that i still
listen to to this day
and really subtly sly social commentary
that tackles
manipulative marketing corporate
feminism and ultimately like
how the pure power of friendship can
literally save the world and even if it
wasn't just such a pure delight it would
be
worth watching to see parker posey and
alan [ __ ] having the time
of their lives as the antagonist but it
really ticks all the boxes and it's just
brimming with infectious enthusiasm
giddy glittery
antics and it's all just the right
amount of camp why do you do
what you do to me baby yep okay see
i just wanted to prove i knew what you
were talking about i never thought about
it as a midnight movie before
i think that it ended up there because
the audience had to find itself right
like it could have been
easily a matinee movie for a bigger
audience but because it wasn't accepted
the right way
it sort of built the subculture around
it it's perfect for like rocking out at
midnight with your friends
you're right and and i think the musical
element it makes sense in the sort of
midnight movie thing when you look at
like a rocky horror picture show
and you want your whole audience
engaging and singing and stuff like that
and also the characters of so many good
one-liners in that movie
i i can't believe people didn't think it
was as funny as it is when it came out
because it makes me
cackle it's great for the midnight movie
vibe like the costumes are so
flourishy and over the top you could
totally dress up for it if you went to a
theater
when those things are happening again
with your friends and be all glittery
and gaudy
just an audience full of those cat ears
that they're like trying to sell in the
movie
but that brings up an interesting point
so what do you think makes
a great midnight movie so i do think
that
josie is a really good example because i
think it is sort of about the
subculture what community that builds up
around these films you know the practice
really took off in the 70s as all the
the daytime slots were taken up by
more mainstream blockbusters family
films award contenders that kind
of movie that everyone wants to go see
the four quadrant films if you will
theaters discovered that they could get
a new audience in later
by showing more provocative off the
beaten path films and
out of that there really did come this
sense of community among midnight films
that you still find to this day it's why
rocky horror has this legendary
decades-long run
of these midnight events same for the
big lebowski has themed events all the
time
they spring up a subculture in a
community around the film and i think
midnight movie even as a descriptor
speaks
more to that community than the content
of the films themselves because they can
be anything they can be horror musicals
comedies
and it's about the community that comes
up around them rather than trying to say
well midnight movies have to be camping
they have to be
b movies it's really up to the audience
to decide i think
that was so well put i love it but i was
expecting to be like
it's gotta be funny you know i don't
know but that was
i love it well thank you so much haley
for coming on the show where can people
find you you can always find me on
collider you can find me on twitter
haleyfuch you can find me on instagram
at haystackmacgroovy
we have a weekly horror podcast called
the witching hour that i host with the
lovely perry nemeroff
i'm easy to find what's a good horror
midnight movie
oh gosh so many i'm trying what like
really gets a crowd going
starship troopers is right on the line
of horror but that gets people
wild really any very hoven robocop
totally
love it would you like to know more
perfect well thank you so much
thank you available to watch in theaters
on friday
kajillionaire she learned to forge
before she learned to write
oh actually that's how she did learn to
write my favorite movies are the ocean
eleven movies
this is exactly the kind of thing that
i've been wanting con
artists teresa and robert have spent 26
years training their only daughter
oldolio to swindle scam and steal at
every opportunity during a desperate
hastily conceived heist
they charm a stranger into joining their
next scam only to have their entire
world turned
upside down the film stars evan rachel
wood
deborah winger gina rodriguez and
richard jenkins
and available to watch at home on friday
ava why would someone not want you to be
alive anymore
what are you talking about
code 8227 confirmed
subjects closed ava played by jessica
chastain is a deadly mercenary who works
for a black ops organization
traveling the globe and specializing in
high-profile hits
ava's career takes a bad turn when a
high-profile job goes wrong
due to faulty information provided to
her with a botched hit
ava is told to take a hiatus until the
heat blows over
but secretly the head of the
organization simon has ordered a hit on
her to ensure
nothing traces back to the company with
the recent death of her father she
decides to go back home in an attempt to
mend her relationship with her mother
and sister
ava must now save her family and herself
from multiple threats while battling her
own demons alright well that's all i got
for you today make sure to check out
that list of midnight movies and let us
know which one is your favorite
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you